- If they put shoulder pads
and cleats on Usain Bolt
it would be Randy Moss.
- The big reason everybody’s
on Trubisky is cuz he was
drafted in the same class
as Mahomes and Watson.
- I know you know football, you’ve
been watchin’ the Jets all season.
- I don’t know if that’s football.
♪♪♪
- Yo, what up?
It is Simms.
- And Lefkoe.
- Appreciate you.
- One thing that we really
care about
is not just talking
about the NFL
but talking about things
that people seem to get wrong.
- Right.
- We see it all the time.
- Setting the narrative straight.
- Yeah.
- It really upsets you.
- It does drive me crazy.
- Why does it upset you so much?
- Well, because a lot of the times
the narrative is false,
I'm finding out.
It's lazy homework done—
- Yes.
- By people in the media
where they just make a take,
and I don't know
if they have any useful
information to back it up.
- I'm gonna set the grains.
- Yeah.
- You go against them.
- OK.
- Earlier in the year and still now—
- Right.
- I see people doubtin'
Mitchell Trubisky.
- Ohh.
- Starts off, "Oh, Seattle game
Green Bay game."
There was a notion
that Mitchell Trubisky
couldn't throw left—
- Yes.
- For a few weeks this year.
- Right.
- That was a popular notion.
What's the truth?
What's the "against the grain"?
- The big reason everybody's
on Trubisky more than anything
is cuz he was drafted
in the same class
as Mahomes and Watson,
and everybody wants that.
- It's tough.
- And that's not fair.
Mahomes got drafted to a team
that was a playoff team.
Watson essentially
got drafted to a team
that was playoff-caliber—
- Had a lot of injuries.
- But had injures to their
quarterback and to other players.
- Trubisky was a true
top-three-pick team.
- A top-three-pick team.
He's got talent, and he's got
talent around him
and that's why
I can't draw a line in the sand
and just go, "He stinks."
That's not fair.
- One team that does not have talent?
- Right.
- The Buffalo Bills,
Sean McDermott.
- Right.
- Three wins thus far.
What's Sean McDermott doing?
You almost think he should be up
for the Coach of the Year
candidacy.
- He should be
in the conversation
for what
Sean McDermott is doing.
- Against the grain.
- Yeah.
I mean, first of all,
this team is not good.
The other thing is,
he's a defensive expert.
They're the No. 1 defense
in football.
Do you know how hard it is to be
the No. 1 defense
in football
when you don't have
an offense or a quarterback
that can do anything?
- When your quarterbacks have
been Peterman and Derek Anderson—
- Exactly.
- For a majority of the season?
- And a rookie, Josh Allen.
They have no receivers on the outside.
- Yeah.
- He manages the game perfectly on
a weekly basis, and I know
he won't win Coach of the Year.
- Yes.
- But he deserves
to be in the convo.
- Can I go against the grain?
- Of course you can.
- Uh, I'm seein' a lot of people
right now goin'
"Oh, Mahomes is good,
but Brees is the MVP.
It's really, like
it's the one thing
he doesn't have in his career.
He's really earned it
at this point.
Mahomes is gonna
have more time."
This is not a lifetime achievement award.
- Yes, exactly.
Drew Brees is not playing better
than Patrick Mahomes.
Drew Brees cannot complete
half the passes
that Patrick Mahomes does.
If you watch the game against
the Bengals—
- Sure.
- Dump-off to Kamara—
- Right, screens.
- Dump-off to Ingram.
- Right.
- I would argue that, probably around 40 percent
of Drew Brees' yards,
are screens, dump-offs
and slants
that get taken to the house.
- And Drew Brees is awesome.
We're not being haters.
- He's great.
- But what, to me
and I think you're
on the right track here
is when you're in the MVP conversation—
- You're a game-changer.
- You are the person
that makes the team go.
- People are hangin' off you,
and you're throwing touchdowns.
- Exactly.
Mahomes makes the team go.
- Yes.
- Todd Gurley makes the Rams go.
- Yes, yes.
- I would argue on the Saints
the O-line and the running back
tandem make the team go.
- So you would put Andrus Peat
in the MVP conversation?
- Well, I mean, their offensive
line and their run game
and then, of course,
Michael Thomas, so I can't sit
there and go, "Drew Brees
is the No. 1 reason
that's making this
team successful."
- Yeah.
- It's a combination of things
and, of course,
he's still playing really good.
- Uh, you've been noticing
a trend of me lately.
- Yes.
- And we're fixing it today.
- Good.
- Yeah.
- Let's do that.
Hey, what's up, slugger?
Ooh.
Welcome to grown-up-hood.
- See how that happened.
- Whoo!
- Don't touch me.
- [Laughing]
- Swag: Nate Burleson has it
by the boatload.
It's flowing.
- Thank you.
- He's got purposeful dirt
on his jeans.
- [Laughing]
- That's incredible.
I've never seen that before.
He's been making fun
of me lately
because every guest we have,
there's an issue
with my handshakes.
- Uh-huh.
- And I don't wanna
show it to you.
I need your help
but I need you to see
what's been happening lately.
- Let's break this down.
- Pleasure.
- Likewise.
Definitely.
It was fun.
- Again, check out
Martellus' show.
- Westbrook, you're the man.
- Thank you.
- Appreciate it.
- You the man.
- Did you see that I went
with the pound?
- Yeah, he's afraid now.
- Because I was intimidated.
- He didn't know which—yeah.
- No, it's just—
- He's afraid.
- I've had, I've just had—
my handshakes haven't
been good lately.
- Listen, first of all—
- Yeah?
- You just gotta
make eye contact.
- OK, OK, OK.
- That's all it is.
All right? And then you gotta
square your shoulders.
You know what I'm sayin'?
I mean, for you.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Cuz for my guy Chris
if I see him, it's like,
"What's up, baby?
How you doin'?
Good to see you."
You know what I'm sayin'?
It's real Chris. That's all it is.
- Yes.
- But like, with you, you gotta
like, square the shoulders.
- Square.
- I think you gotta make
a little eye contact. Not too
much, cuz we're not
making out.
- OK, how high am I going
with the hand?
- Yeah, don't go too high.
Bring it about shoulder-high,
right?
- OK.
- And then you wanna make sure to look
at the elbow.
You know what I'm sayin'?
- Oh, you look at the elbow?
- YOU need to look at the elbow.
- So I abandon eye contact—
- Just know where I'm goin'
with it
cuz, I mean,
if I got a little sauce
and I've known you for a while,
I can come over here
and be like,
"What's up, baby?"
- Ah s--t.
- That's gonna throw you way off.
- I'm scared.
All right, do it again.
- I'm gonna keep it right here.
- Eye contact, square
and then focus on the elbow.
- Yeah, yeah.
- All right, so—
- Yeah.
- What's up, Lef?
- Oh, what's up, man?
- How you doin'? You good?
All right.
I don't need you to lick
your lips like LL Cool J.
- Damn. I did do that.
- [Laughing]
- All right, hold on. Say—
- That was good, though.
- Good contact.
Good confidence.
- Yeah.
- Then what?
Because I have done this
for a long time.
- I don't like that.
So listen, we come in,
we come here.
Boom.
- Yes.
- And then release,
and it has to be straight
when we come here, though.
I saw you come here.
- It was not my fault.
- Yeah, cuz you might as well
just go ahead and kiss
his hand like he's royalty.
- Yes, yes.
- But you know what I'm saying?
You straighten it up.
Bam.
- All right.
- All right, man.
I hope I see Nate today.
- Oh, there he is!
- Oh, Lefkoe. What up, man?
How are you, dude?
- You did it.
- No!
Listen.
I was tryin' to grab it
and you slid out,
and my finger popped up.
- All right. Maybe that's why
I've been doing it.
- Listen. All of our fingers
have to connect. These four.
- All right. Last one. Last one!
- Five on five, here.
You can do it.
- I'm really nervous.
- Hey, Lef.
What up, baby?
- Oh, what up, man?
How are you doin'?
- You good?
- I'm good.
- Ohhh!
- Here we go! That's it. That's it.
And listen, if you ever worry,
you can always hold on
to it for a beat.
You know what I'm sayin'?
- Really?
- Yeah, man.
So you good? How's the fam?
- Oh, that's too much.
- Oh, man, good to see you, man.
- And then I just let go.
- Yeah, you just let go.
Cuz, like—
- Thank you.
- If you don't know whether
it's gonna be a snap, pop
or an extra hit—some guys
like to blow it up afterward.
You can just hold it
and be like
"Yo. What's up? You good?"
- I like that.
- "Hey, I appreciate you having me
on the show, man.
Next time, we gotta talk
some politics."
Like that.
- I'm a snapper.
I'm a snapper at the end
because I went to Texas.
- Yeah, of course.
- Bam.
- You know what I'm saying?
- I'll get to that eventually.
- That's sauce all day, damn.
- I'm sitting between, I think
the two most employed people
in NFL media.
Radio shows, TV shows—
- We're workin'.
- But I mean, what's it like
for both of you guys?
- Once you leave the game,
you realize
"All right, I gotta bust my ass
and work just as hard
in my new craft."
So, like, every opportunity
is like me being a rookie again
and when I was a rookie
I walked in
to the Minnesota Vikings
and I'm seein' Daunte Culpepper
in a Theismann fur
and I'm seein' Randy Moss
swagged out with a baggy suit
and I'm like,
"Damn, this is the NFL."
These dudes pullin' up in
Bentleys with spinners on it.
- Yeah.
- And I'm like—
- In Minnesota.
- "I'm a baby. I'm a baby
and I gotta work."
Not only to make a name
for myself
but to, like,
get these guys' attention
and that was my goal,
to get the greats' attention.
So, like, what we do now
is if we gotta work one
two, three, four jobs, we want
to get attentions of the masses
cuz we're still workin'.
- I do wanna jump off
of something you said
a few minutes ago.
- Oh, Randy Moss?
- Yeah.
- I was gonna say, you
experienced young Randy Moss.
- Right.
- You experienced old Randy Moss.
- The first time
I met Randy Moss,
I knew immediately that
if I got an "attaboy" pat
on the back from him
I've arrived as a wide receiver.
But I went about it
the wrong way
because I was tryin'
to get his attention
like a thirsty dude
at the end of the night.
Like, I was like, "All right,
as soon as I hit him
with this icebreaker,
we're gonna be
best friends forever, man."
- [Laughing]
And I remember one day, I was
getting ready for practice
and I think
it was Jermaine Dupri.
He had a music video, and he's
wearin' the Marshall 88 jersey.
So I'm like in my little
dorm room at training camp.
I was like, "This is it, man."
And I remember,
I was doing conditioning
and I'm standing next to him,
and I'm literally
like, gassin' myself
up like a dude
about to walk across the bar
and ask a girl for their number.
I was like, "All right, man.
Come on.
Don't blow it, don't blow it."
And I was like, "Hey, uh, Randy, um."
Voice was crackin'.
- Yeah.
- I don't know what was goin' on.
I'm a grown man.
And I was like, "Did you see
the Jermaine Dupri video?
He had your jersey on, man."
And he's runnin' next to me.
He looks at me
and he just keeps on runnin'.
I was crushed!
- Ohhh!
- I was like, "Ugh."
Listen, I wrote a girl a note,
"Do you like me, yes or no?"
in the fifth grade,
and she crumpled it up
and threw it at my face.
- Oh, man.
- Randy Moss hurt me more.
Like, my feelings were crushed,
and I was like
"Damn, I blew it."
And then what's crazy is, like,
once I started makin' plays
like, that's when he came in
and was like, "All right."
Like, "I know you love the game
and I know you're one
of the good ones."
- It's funny, I think,
to hear him say that
because I don't think people
always realize
that football players
can also be fanboys.
First time Randy Moss
came on the plane
I was Row 27 by the window,
and he said, "Can I sit here?"
I was like [stuttering]
"Yeah, sure, sure.
You can sit here."
- Yeah, yeah.
- And, I mean,
that's the way I felt
but like Nate's sayin', too
the one thing I learned from him
in a hurry
is his perspective
on the game was, like, amazing.
He could almost see the game
almost like a quarterback.
- Yeah.
- He understood offense
and defense, and, you know
he understood
when this play was stupid
and he wasn't gonna
tell the coach
"That's a stupid play, Simms,"
you know, whatever it was.
- Yeah.
- I mean, and I just, I really
enjoyed being around him.
- Calvin is the forgotten guy.
- Yeah.
- If I'm creating a player
in "Madden"
he's 6'5" running a 4.3,
and his name is Calvin Johnson.
- Yeah.
- But he's never mentioned
in the "Jerry Rice, T.O.,
Randy Moss" top three.
But I would argue
he is physically as gifted
as any of them, if not more.
- No question.
I mean, it's the same individual
that broke Jerry Rice's
single-season record.
- Yeah.
And I watched him do it.
- Right.
- I watched games where
he would put up a buck 90
and we go to the meeting,
and after a loss
Shawn Jefferson,
who's a former player
wide receiver—he was
our wide receivers coach
He'd say, "Calvin, I need you to do more."
- [Laughing]
And, you know, I'm thinkin'
like, "Damn, what you want?
The dude go for 250?"
- Seriously.
- Yeah.
- And Calvin wouldn't
say anything.
He was quiet.
You know, his mother, a doctor.
Dad, he worked on
the railroad,
so he had this blend
of blue-collar and high IQ
and that was his approach
to life
and he would just nod his head
and say, "All right, Coach."
Next game, go put up 300.
Now, Randy was just pure speed
encapsulated.
If they put shoulder pads
and cleats on Usain Bolt
and he was actually a good
football player that can catch
and track the ball like no
other, it would be Randy Moss.
- Yeah.
- And Randy Moss had the greatest
late hands ever.
Even though coaches say, "Don't
panic, remember your cues
don't give anything away,"
like, we panic.
Like, we don't remember our
cues, and we give everything away.
Like, when the ball's
in the air
you start hearing your own
breath, and you go from—
[Panting]
And if you're
a really good DB
I know it's a small detail
but you can hear
a guy breathing hard
and then you see his eyes
go from here to here—
- Yes.
- And that right there is a cue
that something's coming.
- Right.
- Randy would, like, look
and the ball would be comin',
and his face doesn't move
his hands doesn't move,
his breath doesn't move
and then right when it gets
to him, he's like—
Velcro.
Like, that's something
that you might not see ever.
- No.
- I don't think so.
- And that's not something you coach.
It's something that God said
"Hey, Randy, I got
a little extra for you."
- Right. You the man.
- That was awesome.
- Nate Burleson's the man.
- He is the man.
- I think we're gonna
have him back again.
I really do.
- Good.
- You know who else is the man?
Every person on the Rams
and Chiefs roster.
It is the game of the year.
It is the fourth time
since, like, 1990 that two 9-1 teams
have faced off
at this point of the season.
- Yep.
- How good of a game will this be?
Will this be 40-40?
Will it be disappointing?
What's the Simms prediction?
- Well, you know what?
In games like this
more times than not, they don't
live up to the billing
or the expectations
of, like, a shootout, right?
- This year's been different,
though.
Rams-Saints was really good.
- I know, I know.
I guess I always—
- Chiefs-Patriots
was really good.
- It was extremely good.
If you made me bet,
I'm going to say
we're going to get a shootout.
- Whoo!
- We're gonna get a 38-35 type
of football game.
But what happens a lot of times
in these matchups, too
defenses try different
things too
cuz they go, "Man, we can't
really stop this group.
We gotta do something different."
- Which sounds awesome.
- Yes.
- Sounds like 70-yard touchdowns.
- But it can also make
the offense
lose their rhythm too,
just goin'
"Oh, they've never played this
defense versus this coverage."
But either way, I expect a ton
of big-time plays
because it's good play design—
- Yeah.
- And there's talent
on both sides of the ball.
- And I like that both defenses
take risks—
- Yeah.
- Which will allow things deep.
- Exactly right.
- Our question, though,
for this game—
- Right.
- Rams, Chiefs:
Better Big Three.
I think the hardest part about
this is picking your Big Three.
- Ooh!
- I look at the Chiefs.
Is your Big Three Mahomes,
Kareem Hunt and Hill?
- Right.
- Is it Mahomes, Kareem Hunt
and Kelce?
- Yes, right.
- Is it Mahomes, Kelce and Hill?
- Right.
Who would be your Big Three
for the Chiefs?
- Who are you picking?
- Oh my gosh
that's really hard.
I don't even know
which—I mean, gosh.
- All right, well, I'm gonna go
Goff, Gurley and Cooks.
- Cooks is for sure.
- That's set.
- For sure. I mean, yes.
- Who are your Big Three
for the Chiefs?
I gave you, like,
six seconds there.
- Yeah, OK.
I mean, it's obviously Mahomes
and Tyreek Hill.
- OK.
- And I'm gonna go Kareem Hunt as the third.
- I would have gone Kelce. That's an awful decision.
- And I'm sorry, Travis Kelce.
You're really awesome. I know.
- Of those two Big Threes
who you goin' with?
- I am gonna go with the Chiefs
in a close one.
- If I had to make the argument
for the Rams,
cuz I agree with you.
I would take Mahomes
over anybody.
- Yep.
- Mahomes.
- Yes.
- Gurley is, I believe
the best of all
the six players out there.
- OK.
I believe you there.
- I believe that Gurley
is the No. 1 pick—
- Yes.
- If we're not valuing
quarterbacks more.
I think he's the most special.
- OK.
- He's also the guy,
other than Tyreek Hill, that
when he touches the ball, I go,
"What's gonna happen right now?"
- Yeah, you do that
with Mahomes too.
So don't forget that.
- Yeah, you're right.
Hi, I'm Justin Forsett
and you're watching Simms and Lefkoe.
- Guys, I'm embarrassed.
Ever since "The Dragon"
left me hanging
somebody hasn't picked
a game right for one, two
three weeks in a row.
That's not acceptable
for somebody
that likes Lefkoe Locks.
Frankly, we're locked out.
Locked out.
Sean, call a locksmith!
We are in a historic place
right here, AAA Locksmiths.
You've been here in Midtown
for how long, Dave?
- 80-plus years.
We're talkin' changing locks
for Mickey Mantle
lead singer of KISS, who else?
Joe Montana?
- Barbra Streisand,
Harry Winston.
- I'm a man of locks.
I'm a man of Lefkoe Locks
and we have lost three
"Thursday Night Football"
games in a row, Dave,
and I know you know football.
You've been watchin' the Jets
all season.
- I don't know
if that's football.
- That's a good point.
But these two teams
know football
Seattle, Green Bay in Seattle
Seahawks favored by 2.5.
I hear you got a gambling guy
that you asked for a tip.
What did he say?
- He says you gotta go
with the road dog here.
- Who's their quarterback, Dave?
- Aaron Rodgers.
So, it's 2.5 points.
Are you confident in this?
- I'm quite confident.
- Are you confident enough
to make it a Lefkoe Lock?
- Yes.
- It's been locked.
Dave lockin' it up,
takin' the Packers on the road
plus the points, 2.5.
- Dave the Rave.
- Aaron Rodgers and 2.5 points
sounds pretty good.
- Yeah, I mean, I don't know.
It's "Thursday Night Football,"
they're on the road in Seattle
and what scares me—
I'm gonna go
I'm goin' Seahawks, OK?
- OK.
- I'm goin' against Dave the Rave.
Sorry. Negative, Ghost Rider.
But, yeah, I think the run game
of the Seahawks
against a not-so-good
run defense
of the Green Bay Packers—
- At home.
- That scares me a little bit.
- If you take away
the season opener
cuz that's not teams
playing on a short week
the home teams are 7-2,
the average margin of victory
for the "Thursday Night
Football" games is 18 points.
They're not even games.
Simms, I'm seeing these guys
complain on Twitter
the winners,
like the Steelers—
- Yeah.
- Saying, "I'm still not right
from the last game."
- Right.
- These games stink.
- They stink.
- How do we fix this?
What's the issue?
- OK, well, the biggest issue
first of all,
is the coaching, right?
It's a Thursday game,
so there's not—
The coaches lose the chance
to be creative
and add new things
into their game plan.
You don't get a
lotta practice time.
Coaches aren't comfortable—
- I've heard a lot
of coaches say
"We're just gonna
keep it simple."
- Exactly.
That's what they're gonna do.
- So that's why it's not
a great game.
- Well, yeah, exactly right.
- Were you sore?
- I was sore, certainly.
I mean, I'm a wussy quarterback,
and on Thursday mornings
I woke up still sore
after starting a football game on Sunday.
- Wow.
- So imagine how Bobby Wagner
feels or Rashaad Penny
or any other defensive player that's
had to make a lot of big, you know—
- Hits.
- Contact, car crash-type hits.
- Something needs to happen.
- It does.
- Very much so.
- For Simms.
- Peace out, homies.
- I don't know why
I'm so serious right now.
The L-E-F-K-O-E.
- Man.
- I think I'm gonna go with Dave.
- Yeah.
I mean, Aaron Rodgers
always scares me.
- Aaron Rodgers.
- Scary.
- Enjoy the games, guys.
Now, I had a friend that said
I should go, "Heh!"
beforehand so that you—
it's like a downbeat
of when we're gonna do it.
- "Heh."
You make the noise?
- Like a "Heh!"
and then go in.
Don't laugh.
- Who was this friend?
We need to self-evaluate
your friend.
Don't listen to him.
- Veronie! Veronie!
- Don't listen to him.
- All right, so I'm gonna
listen to you.
- You're not playin'
Double Dutch.
You're not, like—
- That's what he said!